in our culture we tend to see
sex as something that's more important
to men than it is to women
but that's not true what is true is that
women often feel more shame
in talking about it over half of women
quietly suffer from
some kind of sexual dysfunction we've
been hearing more about
the orgasm gap it's kind of like the
wage gap but
stickier
straight women tend to reach climax lex
less than 60 percent of the time they
have sex
men reach climax 90 of the time they
to address these issues women have been
sold flawed medication
testosterone creams even
untested genital injections
the thing is female sexuality can't be
fixed with a pill
that's because it's not broken it's
misunderstood
our culture has had a skewed and
medically incorrect
picture of female sexuality going back
centuries if over half of women have
some kind of sexual problem
maybe our idea of sexuality doesn't work
for women we need a clearer
understanding of how
women actually work
i'm a journalist and i recently wrote a
book about
how our understanding of female
sexuality is evolving
so sexuality itself was defined back
when men
dominated science male scientists tended
to see the female body through their own
skewed lens
they could have just asked women about
their experience
instead they probed the female body like
it was a foreign landscape
even today we debate the existence of
female ejaculation
and the g-spot like we're talking about
aliens or ufos
are they really out there all this goes
double for lgbtqi women's sexuality
which has been hated and erased
in specific ways ignorance about the
female body
goes back centuries it goes back to the
beginning of modern medicine
cast your mind back to the 16th century
a time
of scientific revolution in europe
men of ideas were challenging old dogmas
they were building telescopes to gaze up
at the stars
we were making progress sometimes
you see the fathers of anatomy and i say
fathers because
let's face it they were all dudes were
poking about
between women's legs and trying to
classify
what they saw they weren't quite sure
what to do
with a clitoris didn't appear to have
anything to do
with making babies the leading anatomist
at the time declared
that it was probably some kind of
abnormal growth
and that any woman who had one was
probably a hermaphrodite
got so bad that parents would sometimes
have their daughter's clitoris
cut off if it was deemed too large
that's right something we think of today
as female genital mutilation
was practiced in the west as late as the
20th century
you have to wonder if they were that
confused about women's bodies
why didn't they just ask women for a
little help
but you must be thinking oh that was
history
it's a different world now women have
everything they have the birth control
pill
they have sexting and tinder and
bejazzling
things must be better now
but medical ignorance of the female body
continues
how many of you recognize this
it's the full structure of the clitoris
we think of the clitoris as this little
pea-sized
nub but actually it extends deep into
the body
most of it lies under the skin contains
almost as much erectile tissue
as the penis it's beautiful isn't it
it looks a little like a swan
this sculpture is by an artist named
sophia wallace
as part of her cliteracy project
she believes we need more clitoracy and
it's true considering that this
structure
was only fully 3d mapped by researchers
in 2009
that was after we finished mapping the
entire human genome
this ignorance has real life
consequences
in a medical journal in 2005 dr helen
o'connell a urologist
warned her colleagues that this
structure was still
nowhere to be found in basic medical
journals
textbooks like grey's anatomy
this could have serious consequences for
surgery
take this in gentlemen
imagine if you were at risk of losing
your penis
because doctors weren't totally sure
where it was
or what it looked like
unsurprisingly many women aren't too
clear on their own
genital anatomy either you can't really
blame them
the clitoris is often missing from many
sex ed diagrams too
women can sense that their culture views
their bodies with confusion at best
outright disdain and disgust at worst
many women still view their own genitals
as dirty
or inadequate they're increasingly
comparing their vulvas with the neat and
tiny ones they see in pornography
it's one reason why labiaplasty is
becoming a skyrocketing business among
women
and teen girls
some people feel that all this is a
trivial issue
i was writing my book when i was at a
dinner party and someone said
isn't sexuality a first world problem
aren't there aren't women dealing with
more important issues all over the world
of course they are but i think the
impulse to trivialize
sex is part of our problem
we live in a culture that seems obsessed
with sex
we use it to sell everything
we tell women that looking sexy is one
of the most important things you can do
but what we really do is we belittle sex
we reduce it to a sad shadow of what it
truly
is sex is more than just an
act i spoke with dr laurie brato
a psychologist who treats sexual issues
in women
including survivors of trauma she says
the hundreds of women she sees
all tend to repeat the same thing they
say i don't feel
whole they feel they've lost a
connection with their partners
and themselves so what
is sex we traditionally define
the act of sex as a linear
goal-oriented process it's something
that starts with lust
continues to heavy petting and finishes
with a happy ending
except many women don't experience it
this way
it's less linear for them and more
circular this is a new model of women's
arousal and desire developed by dr
rosemary basson it says many things
including that women can
begin an encounter for many different
reasons
that aren't desire like curiosity
they can finish with a climax or
multiple climaxes or satisfaction
without a climax at all
all options are normal
some people are starting to champion a
richer
definition of sexuality whether you
identify as male female or neither
gender
sex is about our relationship to the
senses
it's about slowing down listening to the
body
coming into the present moment it's
about our whole health and well-being
in other words sex at its true breadth
isn't profane it's sacred
that's one reason why women are
redefining their sexuality today
they're asking what is sex for me
so they're experimenting with practices
that are less about the happy ending
more about feeling whole so they're
trying out spiritual sex
classes masturbation workshops
even shooting their own porn that
celebrates the diversity
of real bodies for anyone who still
feels this is a trivial issue consider
this
understanding your body is crucial to
the huge
issue of sex education and consent
by deeply and intimately knowing what
kind of touch
feels right what pressure what speed
what context you can better know what
kind of touch feels wrong
and have the confidence to say so
this isn't ultimately about women having
more or better sex
it's not about making sure women have
have as many orgasms as men
it's about accepting yourself and your
own
unique experience it's about you being
the expert
on your body it's about defining
pleasure and satisfaction on your terms
and if that means your happiest having
no sex at all
that's perfect too if we define
sex as part of our whole health and
well-being
then empowering women and girls to fully
own it
is a crucial next step toward equality
and i think it would be a better world
not just for women
but for everyone thank you